in death as in life he was a master of
ceremony and disruption his presence
drawing crowds
outside the Cathedral of Milan the city
that made him empowered his rise to the
top fans of AC Milan the football team
he once owned gave their final goodbye
[Applause]
a final glimpse of the man who became an
unshakable force in Italian politics
remaking it in his own image a source
for some of inspiration for others
infamy
even the national day of mourning
declared in his honor and the state
funeral were for many too much of a
tribute for a leader known for his Brash
style and sleazy scandals but for his
supporters A fitting tribute to the Man
known as
the night
what a man is a character he is always
on stage he has fans and detractors he
has people cheering for him and people
hating him Sylvia Berlusconi was
certainly a politician he was certainly
a businessman he was certainly a
character to the four of celebrity
Archer leaves behind another struggle
Revival of his power
ful
one of the parties that make up Italy's
coalition government one that the Prime
Minister JoJo Maloney depends on for the
survival of her Premiership
for all his controversy Berlusconi
managed to unite Italy's right-win
parties and facilitated the rise of
Meloni but in recent times he was
increasingly at odds with her
without Berlusconi the government finds
itself in a fragile position Maloney
needs 17 senators from ports Italia to
consolidate her Coalition government's
majority key to maintaining support
Willie berlusconi's daughter Marina who
oversees his business Empire as well as
the late Leader's girlfriend Martha
fascina herself a senior member of forts
Italia in the lower house for sitalia's
prospects will depend on these three
women they and the party supporters will
be key to whether berlusconi's political
Legacy is able to survive into the
future
Al Jazeera